Wir blicken auf den europäischen Fußball bei den Männern. Das heißt heute ein bisschen Champions League und ein bisschen La Liga, ein bisschen Serie A. Das ist das Menü einer etwas anderen Ligatur. Schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid. Schön, dass Mario Rieker und Nils Kern mit dabei sind. Jetzt geht's los.
Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Ich hab Bock. Wie sieht's bei dir aus, Nils? Schön, dass du da bist. Guten Morgen.
Ja, Buenos Dias. Hier ist ja fast so viel los wie im Parkhaus oder in der U-Bahn nach einem Heimspiel des FC Bayern.
Moment mal, das ist natürlich, hier ist es ja gerade leer.
Also das kann ja nicht wahr sein.
Standst du noch ein bisschen im Stau? Kann das sein?
So ungefähr, ja. Das ist einfach wild. Man bleibt schon noch 90 Minuten im Stadion drin. Und trotzdem, wie kriegt ihr das einfach nicht hin?
Ja, es ist ganz faszinierend. Ich habe beim letzten Arsenal-Spiel, bin ich dann irgendwann aus der Mix, weil ich mir nichts mehr erwartet habe und sollte auch recht behalten. Da kam nichts mehr. Und dann habe ich gerade noch so die letzte U-Bahn nach Hause erwischt, weil natürlich nach 1 Uhr, da möchte niemand mehr nach Hause kommen, denkt sich München. Da ist ein guter, rechtschaffender Bürger zu Hause, konsumiert keinen Cannabis und gendert auch nicht. Deswegen bin ich tatsächlich diesmal mit dem Fahrrad gefahren. Das hat sich gelohnt, schön eine Stunde. Aber danach war ich wieder wach, als ich zu Hause war. Mario, schön, dass du auch da bist.
Ja, freut mich. Ich hatte zum Glück keinen Parkplatz-Trouble. Ich muss sagen, ich bin so gut wie noch nie vorbereitet, weil ich habe in guter Rasenfunken-Manier beide Champions-League-Spiele so halb Real-Life geguckt, weil der Sohn so spät geschlafen hat. Ich habe jetzt mal gemerkt, wie du dich fühlst. Vor allem habe ich beim Dortmund-Spiel den Fehler gemacht, irgendwann zwischendurch so in Geistesumnachtung, weil ich irgendwas in der Serie B nachgucken wollte, in der Tabelle habe ich die App aufgemacht und dann gesehen, wie es steht und dachte, oh nein.
Das ist natürlich Anfängerfehler, Mario. Das ist genauso wie, ganz wichtig, die Spiele, die man guckt, die man live guckt, da muss man den Toralarm ausmachen. Ich sage den Anbieter nicht dazu, aber bei einem Anbieter muss man auch immer, wenn man live guckt, auf jeden Fall den Toralarm ausmachen. Sonst wird man nämlich über so etwas wie Schlusspfiff, Tore usw. auch schon gespoilert.
Aber bald ist der Saisonende und dann haben wir es geschafft.
Die Frage ist nur, wann für uns alle Saisonende sein wird, wie weit das noch gehen wird. Lasst mal mit der Champions League beginnen. Wir wollen, weil es etwas besondere Champions League-Halbfinale sind, aus deutscher Sicht da mal kurz drauf schauen. Lass mal mit BVB gegen PSG beginnen. Am Ende, Mario, macht es natürlich, wie wir alle auf unserer Bingo-Karte hatten vor zwei Jahren, Föhlkrug. Der macht das entscheidende Tor im Champions League-Halbfinale. Ich habe den damals bei Hannover gesehen und dachte mir gleich, das wird passieren. Ich hatte dann ein Gefühl wie Thomas Tuchel bei Serge Nabry. Nur, dass ich richtig lag.
Wild, für mich steht vor allem irgendwie die Überschrift drüber, wie kann Dortmund dieses Spiel zu Null spielen? Also das ist das Match Glück für zehn Jahre aufgebraucht, würde ich sagen. Also nicht, dass es irgendwie ein glücklicher Sieg unterm Strich war. Ich finde, sie haben schon genug dafür getan, dass man auch sich danach feiern lassen kann. Aber bei der Chancenmasse, die PSG teilweise gut rausgespielt hat, teilweise auch einfach nur mit Pech. Diese zwei Pfosten in der 51 war das. Dann waren aber natürlich noch ein paar Sachen dabei, wie Fabian Ruiz ist auf jeden Fall kein Kopfballspieler, habe ich mir jetzt schon mal notiert.
Aber geiler Pass hinter die Kette auf ihr.
Ich fand das in der Anfangsphase super spannend, weil ich da auch noch ohne Ton geguckt habe. Und wenn man dann gerade in den ersten 10 bis 15 Minuten, ich habe PSG nicht so oft gesehen und habe da in dem Moment noch nicht in die Apps reingeguckt und kannte auch nicht alle Spieler. So in der totalen Entschuldigung. Dann habe ich mir immer wieder neue Notizen gemacht, in welcher Systematik die es denn spielen. Weil das fand ich spannend, wie variabel das die ganze Zeit bei denen ist. Also Hakimi schiebt hoch, deswegen war auf der Seite ja auch Adeyemi so beschäftigt, den man wirklich, ich glaube Marco Hagemann hat es auch das eine oder andere Mal gemacht, aber zurecht auch, dass dessen Leistung wirklich sagenhaft gut war. Vor allem, weil das in den letzten Wochen nicht immer der Fall war. Ein Offensivspieler, der so engagiert mit nach hinten arbeitet, habe ich am Dienstag zum Beispiel nicht gesehen. Aber dazu kommen wir vielleicht später noch. Also ich fand es war eine extrem geschlossene Mannschaftsleistung von Dortmund, die aber selber auch immer wieder sich nach so 10-15 Minuten Leidensphasen super gut selber gelöst haben und dann auch Phasen hatten, in denen sie das Spiel dominiert haben. Deswegen, wie ich gesagt habe, unterm Strich finde ich, ist der Heimsieg in Ordnung. Ich bin mir nur nicht sicher, ob das 1-0 dann auf die ganze Strecke reicht. Es gab ja auch noch eine Chance, vor allem die von Föhlkrug in der 60. die er machen muss, finde ich. Und in der 84. habe ich mir noch aufgeschrieben, da brandt, wo es eigentlich gut macht und Föhlkrug viel besser postiert ist als Reus. Wenn da Reus nicht zum Kopfball geht, dann... Auf der anderen Seite, die 81., da pennt der BVB, habe ich mir aufgeschrieben, das war glaube ich auch so ein schöner Ball hinter die Kette, wo die zusammen... Also da sieht man danach Can, wie er lacht, aber wenn der reingeht, dann sprechen wir wieder, das ist genau der BVB, dann reißen sie sich selber wieder ein, weil da muss ja der BVB das Tor machen, und dann sprechen wir wieder irgendwie über eine komplett ungeordnete BVB-Defensive, die sich irgendwie den Heimsieg kaputt macht.
Ich glaube, deswegen hat er auch gelacht, weil er gesagt hat, wie kann denn der so einfach hier an die Grundlinie gehen und an den Rückraum passen. Also ich glaube, es ging so Richtung Mitspieler macht mal. Aber Nils, damit du mehr sagen darfst als Mh-mh und Zustimmung, wie fandest du es denn?
Ich würde erstmal ein bisschen den Hut ziehen vor dem BVB für was für eine intensive Partie, das war laufstark, auch ein Sancho auf einmal wieder, der hat es doch noch drauf. Ich fand bemerkenswert, was auch Adeyemi sich defensiv reingeworfen hat und Chan auch sehr viel geblockt. Home ist natürlich ein super Spiel. Und trotzdem hat auch BVB immer ein bisschen das Risiko gesucht, also die vielen kurz ausgeführten Abschläge, wo man sich gedacht hat, da macht ihn doch gleich mal lang, der PSG geht doch immer noch drauf, die haben die Energie, die haben die Power, auch in der 80. Minute euch noch mit 3 Mann vorne, also im eigenen Strafraum zu pressen. Aber es hat irgendwie funktioniert, also diese leichte Risikobereitschaft hinten mit kurz ausführen und dann irgendwie schnell in das Handschuh schicken. Es hat ja trotzdem irgendwo funktioniert, auch wenn hier und da das Glück hast du gebraucht, ja auch bei den beiden Aluminium-Szenen gar keine Frage, aber Chapeau dafür, für so eine Power-Energieleistung mit dem Stadion zusammen, war schon irgendwo beeindruckend, man hat mitgelitten. Auch wenn natürlich irgendwo vom XG-Wert und allem verdientermaßen hätte sich bestimmt PSG das ein oder andere Türchen verdient, aber wer jetzt verdient, verdient der Ergebnisse, kann ich als Matrilene jetzt auch nicht immer die ganze große, den Mund groß aufmachen.
Also XG-Werte waren 1, 78 zu 1, 7, also ausgelesen. Interessanterweise das andere Spiel, über das wir sprechen werden, 1, 58 zu 1, 9 und da waren noch zwei Strafstöße mit dabei. Das war der kleine Unterschied. Ja, ich meine, es gab auch noch diese große Chance von Saarbezer, wo Völkruck noch mal stark ablegt. Das war unmittelbar, glaube ich, nach dem 1 zu 0. Es hätte früher 2 zu 0 sein können. Aber ja, ich fand auch, so wie man es jetzt in dieser Saison jetzt schon ein paar Mal erlebt hat, in Heimspielen, in der Champions League, natürlich nicht ganz so temporeich wie Atletico. Das lag aber halt auch daran, dass es das Hinspiel war. Also einer von beiden musste ja nicht komplett aufmachen, um quasi irgendwie einen Rückstand aufzuholen und dann konnte man kontern. Sancho fand ich überragend. Richtig, richtig starkes Spiel gemacht. Dann auch im Interview mit einem angetrunkenen Jamie Carragher stabil geblieben. Habt ihr das mitbekommen? Also bei CBS ist das, glaube ich, wo ja im Studio saßen Alessandro Del Piero, der ja auch bei Bayern gegen Real war, ein sehr netter Mensch. Hat mich sehr nett durch die Reihe durchgelassen und musste, weil er am Gang saß, sehr viele Selfies machen, der Arme da hat die Bayern-Medien-Abteilung ihn nicht so nett platziert. Also Alessandro Del Piero, Michael Richards und Thierry Henry sind im Studio. Und als Interviewer vor Ort sind Peter Schmeichel und Jamie Carragher. Und Jamie Carragher ist in die gelbe Wand gegangen und hat da viele Freunde gemacht, hat auch gleich das gemacht, was man da halt auf jeden Fall gar nicht macht, nämlich ein Selfie-Video gedreht, auf dem du tausend um ihn herumstehende Fans auch erkennst nach dem 1 zu 0. Und er konnte nicht aufhören, davon zu erzählen, wie toll es war und dass er jetzt auch schon ein bisschen was getrunken hätte und er war auch ziemlich alkohol-verherrlichend, das muss man wirklich sagen. Erste Frage war, bist du überhaupt noch nüchtern genug für dieses Interview? Und dann hat er, als er sich mit Peter Schmalche darüber unterhalten hat, Jaden Sancho gesehen, hat gesagt, Jaden, Jaden, komm her! Und dann musste Jaden Sancho sich von einem dann doch ein bisschen angetrunkenen Jamie Carragher interviewen lassen. Aber er hat das, wie auf dem Feld, sehr souverän gelöst, muss man sagen. Also kann man, ich kann ja mal einen Tweet verlinken, da ist aktuell das Video noch zu finden. Mal gucken, ob es noch copyright-claimed wird, aber ich verlinke es auf jeden Fall.
Aber Jaden Sancho in 90 Minuten über 100 Ballkontakte in einem Spiel, wo du gar nicht so viel Ballbesitz hast, wo du klar mehr dem Gegner überlässt, das war schon herausragend. Auch diese Doppelchance, wo er dann nochmal nachsetzt und dann auch nochmal dann, ich glaube, den was dann der Kopfball vom Phil Krupp vorbereitet, das ist schon ein Riesenspiel von ihm gewesen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Und das ist aber halt auch interessant, und das haben wir ja dann gleich beim Bayern-Spiel auch, eben diese Aggressivität gegen den Ball mal richtig zu sehen. Also bei Adhemi hast du es quasi am Plakatisten gesehen, aber es geht ja um alle Spieler. Also ganz oft waren die Spieler zu zweit gegen die Pariser. Ganz, ganz wenige 1 gegen 1-Duelle zumindest in den quasi entscheidenden Zonen. Strafraum sehr gut verteidigt. Es hat ja auch ewig gedauert, bis es den ersten Schuss aufs Tor vom BVB gab. Das war erst in der zweiten Hälfte, dass Kogel mal einen Schuss aufs Tor halten musste, der irgendwie halbwegs gefährlich war. Und das, obwohl PSG, ihr habt es ja gesagt, so variabel war, so viel verändert hat. Was man schon wieder deutlich gemerkt hat, also es gab Gründe, Mbappé ins Zentrum zu stellen. Aber der ist halt auf dem Flügel so viel besser, wie oft der quasi Schwung geholt hat und dann gemerkt hat, geil, ich dribbe hier gerade gegen drei. Das schaffe ja nicht mal ich. Okay, gut, ich breche wieder ab und gebe den Ball auf den Flügel. Das fand ich interessant. Also ich glaube, dass in den französischen Medien kritischer über dieses Spiel gesprochen werden wird, weil eigentlich so manche Aufstellungsideen, Bakula auf dem Flügel, Mbappé im Zentrum, später kam dann Mouarni und dann natürlich auch die Abwehrfrage. Ich meine, das hat sich jetzt durch die Verletzung von Lucas Anandas wahrscheinlich erledigt fürs Rückspiel. Aber da gab es schon so ein paar Themen, die man noch mal diskutieren hätte können. Auch Ruiz zum Beispiel im Mittelfeld. Welche Rolle hatte Ruiz? Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich habe ihn seit langer Zeit mal wieder über 90 Minuten gesehen. Ich fand ihn ja bei Napoli immer so geil. Da war es ja auch eigentlich einer so, einer, der... Gut, jetzt hat er da dann auch die Chancen gehabt. Wenn er es macht, dann rede ich wahrscheinlich anders drüber. Aber der schon diese Qualität hat, auch in der Zone vor dem Strafraum und auch mit einer gewissen Körperlichkeit und Geschwindigkeit dann da mehr zu initiieren. Aber der Raum war schon irgendwie auch ein bisschen eingenommen davon, dass da Mbappé in der Mitte gespielt hat. Und der dann da auch immer seine Freiheiten braucht und so. Aber das fand ich vor allem die ersten 20 Minuten, wenn man da Mbappé beobachtet hat, wie kannst du 20 Minuten lang in so einem wichtigen Spiel eigentlich einen solchen Spieler durch seine Aufstellung gar nicht richtig integrieren ins Spiel? Und dann kommt auch Mojani rein und dann bleibt der auf dem Flügel und Mbappé bleibt trotzdem zentral. Und wenn wir da beim Coaching sind, ich fand es super spannend zu beobachten, weil jetzt hatten wir irgendwie 4 Trainer, die ganz unterschiedlich sind. Luis Enrique ist ja Wahnsinn, wie aktiv der coacht. Also er kommentiert ja wirklich gefühlt jeden Schritt seiner Kette hinten und wo, was, wie draufschieben. Also fraglich, wie viel davon ankommt, aber das ist schon eher so, wenn du das jetzt irgendwie mit einem Angelotti vergleichst. Verhältnismäßig, am Dienstag die ersten 10 Minuten, so viel Bewegung habe ich den noch nie gesehen. Ich habe kurz Angst um sein Herz gehabt. Der ist sogar nach 5 Minuten da mal direkt zu seinem Sohnemann auf die Bank und hat sich irgendwas auf dem Monitor angeguckt. Das ist spannend gewesen.
Und es ist ja die perfekte Überleitung zum 2. Spiel, würde ich sagen. Bayern gegen Real am Ende 2 zu 2. Das habt ihr alle mitbekommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und Nils war, so wie ich, auch im Stadion und konnte ja auch Carlo Ancelotti beobachten. Ich fand es dennoch faszinierend. Er steht ja dann immer mit angewinktem Arm und man sieht ihn nur von hinten. Und man weiß aber, dass die Augenbraue gerade oben ist. Dafür habe ich ihn schon oft genug gesehen. Warum musste er denn so viel korrigieren? Wie hat dir denn das Spiel gefallen, Nils?
Ancelotti hat ja ein bisschen das Thema Intensität hat gefehlt. Es gab ja schon gleich zu Beginn diese Chance von Was Sané und dann die Fußparade von Lunin. Also, dass Dario vielleicht ein bisschen zu locker das Spiel angegangen ist. Und deswegen dann auch mal ein Carlo Ancelotti, die mal nur eine Hand vielleicht in der Westentasche hat, in der Hosentasche hat. Und trotzdem hatte ich jetzt gar nicht so viel mehr erwartet, weil hinspiel, Real Madrid hatte eigentlich bessere Personallage. Und alles ist mehr die Mannschaft, die mehr leiden, mehr aushalten kann. Also, ich habe jetzt nicht in Real Madrid erwartet, dass so aktiv so viel ins Risiko gehen wird, all in gehen wird, weil einfach noch dieser Ass im Ärmel ist mit dem Rückspiel zu Hause. Deswegen hatte ich sogar auch 2-2 getippt. Und ich habe jetzt den FC Bayern nicht oft gesehen, aber manche sagen, das war das beste Spiel der Saison. Bei Real Madrid kann man sagen, die haben jetzt auch nicht locker irgendwie sind zum Punkt gekommen, aber da war auf jeden Fall noch Luft nach oben. Und das war noch lange nicht Real Madrid am Limit, wenn sie dann erst mal auch aktiver spielen und den Gegner nicht nur rauslocken, um dann einen langen Ball Richtung Viennizes zu schlagen. Also, da geht schon auch mehr, aber der FC Bayern muss sich da bestimmt auch noch dann mehr strecken. Noch ein bisschen mehr als eh schon im Rückspiel, weil das war jetzt ja Madrid wie ein bisschen gegen Leipzig, vielleicht auch so nicht verwaltungsmussend. Und trotzdem erst mal, wir schauen mal, was der Gegner macht. Wir warten einfach mal ab und vielleicht geht noch ein langer Ball Richtung Viennizes durch. Wir bekommen noch unsere Chance. So war es dann auch mit dem späten 2-2, wo dann einfach da nochmal gute Kombination, Rodrigo im Strafraum gefällt. Also, das war, von dem her war das. Habe ich jetzt nicht viel Enttäuschung unter den Matridistas. Ich war im Gästenblock gesehen, sondern ja, wenn du das 2-2 erzielst, als es zu kassieren, ist das ja eher schon mal so, jawoll, jetzt kriegt man das Rückspiel. Juno-Wembley gebucht.
Ich habe Fragen, Nils. Eine generelle, zur ersten Hälfte. Und zwar, ich fand die Rolle von Valverde total interessant. Also, Valverde nominell rechts außen in der taktischen Formation mit Ball schon deutlich eingerückt. Und de facto war der aber 6er, 8er, 10er. Ich hatte das Gefühl, dass Valverde derjenige war, der immer das Dreieck auffüllen sollte. Also, zwei waren immer da. Und Valverde hat versucht, die Spitze des Dreiecks zu sein. Oder die Seite des Dreiecks. Also, eine der drei Spitzen vom Dreieck. Spielt der das immer so? Oder war das was Besonderes? In der zweiten Hälfte sah es dann deutlich anders aus. Aber in der ersten ist mir das total aufgefallen.
Man kann bei Valverde auf jeden Fall beschreiben, dass er so der große Löcherstopfer in dieser Mannschaft ist. Auch mit Rüdiger, der spieler mit den meisten Minuten. Der gar nicht immer auffällt durch den einen Zweikampf oder durch die eine Torbeteiligung. Da hat er jetzt nicht überschaubare Statistiken, aber er ist einfach überall auf dem Feld. Hilft speziell, wenn hinten rechts nicht der Stammverteidiger spielt. In dem Fall war es jetzt Lukas Vazquez. Da durfte er ab und zu mal aushelfen, aber wirklich auch von der Heatmap her überall rot auf dem Feld gewesen, gefühlt. Und dass er einfach wirklich auch diese Freiheit hat vom Trainer, der ihm sagt, du verstehst dein Spiel, du weißt, wo du helfen kannst. Du hast auch die Ausdauer, die Laufleistung, Box-to-Box-mäßig überall auf dem Feld zu sein. Und das 90 Minuten, der fällt wirklich irgendwann um, weil er einfach nicht mehr kann. Merkt er aber nicht, dass er gleich nicht mehr können wird, sondern er würde einfach umfallen. Und das, weil er schon dieser Löcherstopfer, der sich dann eben auch immer wieder anbietet im Zusammenspiel, aber auch eben, um dann zu doppeln, den Gegenspieler. Da ist er wirklich seine Leistung, ist da immer eine ganz, ganz wichtige auf dem Feld.
Fand ich total interessant zu sehen und auch sehr, sehr schwer für Bayern zu greifen. Hat allerdings gar nicht so oft zu Szenen geführt. Also, er hat auch ganz oft, es standen sie zwei gegen eins gegen Masrawi, aber halt immer Ball fern, weil Sané eingerückt ist. Aber dann hat es immer zu lange gedauert, bis der Ball dahin gekommen ist. Aber braucht man ja nicht, man kann ja auch Mario einfach einen Verteidiger aus seiner Position ziehen und dann tief durchspielen. Also, sowohl der Passweg dürfte nicht offen sein und natürlich auch diese Szene. Und das ist ja der andere Blick, den man auf dieses Spiel haben kann. Also, ich verstehe total deinen Ruhepuls, Nils, weil du hast das einfach schon 15 Millionen Mal erlebt, dass Real Madrid genauso die Champions League gewinnt, mit dieser Art zu spielen. Man kann es aber ja auch negativ formulieren, kann sagen, es hat zwei klare Abwehrfehler gebraucht, eines Spielers, das war Min-Jae Kim, damit diese beiden Tore gefallen sind. Wo wärst denn du auf dieser Skala?
Ja, ich glaube, dass Real in dem Spiel auch Tore macht ohne die Abwehrfehler irgendwann. Dass es das natürlich hätte, wenn und aber, mit hartes bisschen Leid für Min-Jae, wie dann auf ihm rumgehackt wurde. Klar, das ist dann immer wieder der Letzte in der Kette, in dem Fall wirklich in der Kette, der dann einen Fehler macht, der bestraft wird, Torhüter oder Verteidiger. Ich fand, ansonsten, schon in der Phase, rundum, wo das Tor fällt, hat man so gemerkt, dass das Spiel ein bisschen kippt. Das waren die ersten 15 Minuten. Hat Real extrem viele Ballverluste auch gehabt, weil Bayern sehr gut breitmaschig so angelaufen ist. Das hat super funktioniert mit Kane und Müller, weil sie dann Müller höher gegangen ist. Da hatte ich echt das Gefühl, seit Langem, als ich ein Realspiel gesehen habe, die sind kurz davor, zu schwimmen, weil sie auch in der Vorwärtsbewegung so viele Ballverluste hatten. Ich hatte eine Beobachtung. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr die auch hattet. Es ist ein bisschen besser geworden als... Das war rund um die 18. Minute. Da ist Bellingham auf einmal sehr viel tiefer gekommen als davor. Kroos hat sich erst ein bisschen links in den Aufbau fallen lassen. Dann hatte Kroos viel öfter den Ju zum Anspielen. Dann hat sich daraufhin auch Bayern ein bisschen zurückgezogen. Dann kam es auf einmal wieder, dass es einen Realtakt bekommen hat, von dem man in den ersten 15 Minuten gar nichts gesehen hat. Da haben sie die Bälle verteilt. Dadurch konnte Kroos im Spiel mit Bellingham, da haben sie sich etwas vorgearbeitet. Dann kommt Kroos bei diesem Pass in diesen freien Raum, wo überhaupt kein Balldruck mehr da ist. Was dann... Was dann... Munchen macht das natürlich irre. Und vor allem auch, wie er geil danach italienisch in Richtung Kimmich so... Ich glaube, er wollte ja, dass Kimmich einrückt. Aber so schnell ist ja nicht mal Josh Kimmich, dass er da hinten den Raum schließt. Und ich fand das fantastisch, wie Kimm da... Also, das sah so aus, als hätte er das Gefühl, dass Kimmich da den Fehler gemacht hat.
Na, er ist zumindest quasi in der Gewissheit rausgerückt, dass jemand für ihn die Lücke stopft. Weil er das ganz offensichtlich so gelernt hat. Aber da siehst du halt, es ist halt nicht nur, glaube ich, der Einzelspieler, natürlich war das eine falsche Entscheidung. Bei beiden Dingen, vor allem das Foul auch, darf in der Form, wenn Dyer schon dazu kommt, uns zu helfen, musste Rodrigo nicht so doof zu Boden bringen. Aber die spielen halt zu selten in dieser Formation zusammen. Und er ist halt auch jetzt die 1-B-Lösung. Deswegen spielt er auch nicht mehr. Deswegen haben die halt keine Automatismen. Das ist halt absolut verrückt. Ich meine, wir haben halt jetzt Mai. Dieses Spiel war noch Ende April. Und trotzdem haben die halt keine Automatismen. Kimmich weiß nicht, dass er da reinrücken soll. Und wäre er auch nicht schlau gewesen, weil dann wäre auf dem Flügel was frei gewesen. Klar, lieber auf dem Flügel als im Zentrum. Aber es ging halt auch wahnsinnig schnell. Das ist ja genauso, wie dann wird Luca Modric irgendwann eingewechselt. Und spielt halt diesen überragenden Luca Modric-Pass, wo man wirklich runtergehen möchte und ihm den Fuß kuss möchte und sagen möchte, danke Luca, dass ich das nochmal live sehen darf. Und gleichzeitig stellt man sich die Frage, warum hat das ganze Spiel über, außer Toni Kruz, kein anderer diesen Pass gespielt? Aber weil halt keiner Luca Modric ist. Das ist schon faszinierend, dass Real Madrid einfach auf einem Level ist, wo sie jederzeit aus nichts Gefahr erzeugen können. Und Bayern das zu spüren bekommen hat, obwohl Bayern ein gutes Spiel gemacht hat. Ob es das Beste der Saison war, weiß ich ehrlicherweise nicht. Ich fand, dass da Arsenal schon überzeugender war und das Rückspiel gegen Lazio, wobei da wahrscheinlich der Gegner auch nicht so gut war. Aber Bayern hat ja ein sehr gutes Spiel gemacht. Real war, fand ich, zwischendurch. Es gab eine Phase, wo sie wirklich geschwommen sind, nämlich direkt nach dem 1 zu 2, wenn da irgendwie da ja das 3 zu 1-Kopf, dann geht das Spiel in die andere Richtung. Also, Nils, wir haben jetzt viele Punkte angesprochen.
Ja, also, dass bei den Bayern vielleicht hier und da Abstimmungsfehler nicht ganz eingespielt ist, hat man gemerkt. Und Real Madrid auf der anderen Seite ist dann eben so eine eingespielte, geölte Maschine. Ich meine, du hast auch mit Bellingham einen neuen in dieser Saison in der Startelf dabei. Aber die Mannschaft kennt sich halt so gut, versteht sich so blind, dass da eben automatisch dann Löcher gestopft werden, dass du kaum noch reden musst. Auch Toni Kroos, da reicht ein Blick und schon startet einer. Das ist einfach da ein sehr, sehr guter Zusammenhalt, wo sich die Jungs gut kennen, gut verstehen, ohne jetzt immer groß privat was zu machen. Aber einfach diese Teambonding in der Mannschaft ist einfach so hoch. Und Real Madrid hat einfach auch dieses Selbstvertrauen zu warten, auf diese eine Chance. Klar, war das jetzt wieder ein Fehler von Kemo. Und es gab auch schon Fehler von Sven Ulreich gegen Real Madrid. Oder Real Madrid hat auch schon von Fehlern provoziert, von Karius, von Donnarum und anderen. Aber Real Madrid wartet eben auch, provoziert ein bisschen diese Fehler, hat diesen leicht minimalistischen Ansatz, um einfach auf diese Chance zu warten. Und es kommt halt immer. Und so ist Real auch in dieser Saison jetzt mit. Ich glaube, in der Champions League sind es jetzt vier Unentschieden. So gesehen in Folge in der Champions League, wenn man das und Elfmeterschießen gegen Man City so betrachtet. Das gab es noch nie in Real Madrids Historie. Also da sind sie ja ein bisschen gerade auf Titelkurs wie Portugal bei der EM 2016, die auch kaum mal ein Spiel innerhalb von 90 Minuten gewonnen haben. Aber trotzdem hat das gereicht. Und Real Madrid weiß genau das. In der Saison wurde auch drei Kreuzbandrisse. Und viele andere Verletzte. Bayern haben auch Verletzungen, schon klar. Aber Ancelotti weiß dann schon auch, seine Werkzeuge so einzusetzen. Und dann hat er nur gefühlt 12, 13, 14, Startelf-Kandidaten. Aber die kennen sich halt so gut. Die sind so leidensfähig. Die haben so eine hohe Laufbereitschaft. Auch eine gute Regeneration. Vinicius Bellingham, Valverde unter hoher Belastung. Immer noch fit zu sein für die Spiele. Dass es irgendwie funktioniert. Und dass der Gegner dann trotzdem oft irgendwo sich müde läuft und einfach nicht durchkommt. Ohne, dass das jetzt der ultimative Beton ist, den Real Madrid anrührt. Das war es im Man City-Rückspiel, ja. Aber es hat auch, wie gesagt, mit nicht minimalem Aufwand gereicht. Aber wie gesagt, da war noch Luft nach oben. Ich glaube, da wird man dann im Rückspiel auch mehr Risikobereitschaft sehen. Jetzt nehmen wir mal das Heft in die Hand. Dann kommen noch ein paar mehr tödliche Pässe vielleicht von großem Modric und Co., weil die einfach genau wissen, jetzt startet wieder einer. Und ob es dann wieder Rodrigo links ist oder Bellingham, die tiefer sucht, da bist du dann doch irgendwo sehr variabel auch.
Ja, aber ich fand, es war ein hochinteressantes Spiel, auch aus Bayerns Sicht, weil in der ersten Hälfte war es so, dass Toni Groß sich immer in Musiala orientiert hat, also nicht in Mandeckung, aber hat immer geguckt, wo ist Musiala, und ist dann so ein bisschen in seinen Raum gegangen, weil er halt einfach weiß, dem darfst du nicht so viele Schritte geben. Interessanterweise einen Moment, wo er mal zu viel Raum gelassen hat, da fällt dann dieser Freistoß kurz vor der Hälfte. Das war ja die erste Chance wieder für Bayern nach dem 0 zu 1. Das hat ja eine ganze Weile gedauert, ich glaube 42. Minute oder so. Und in der zweiten Hälfte dann war es so, dass Thomas Müller ja dann eher im Zentrum gespielt hat. Es gab also eine leichte Anpassung. Also einmal muss Jaller und Sané tauschen die Seiten. Sehr gute Idee. Habt man mal beiden Toren gesehen. Und Thomas Müller geht eher in so eine 4-2-3-1, also eher in so eine zentrale Position. Und Müller hat jeden Ball, den er bekommen hat, der quasi mit einer entsprechenden Schafe gespielt war, ins Zentrum mitgenommen und ist so quasi an groß vorbeigegangen. So entsteht der Elfmeter. Und durch so einen Laufweg macht er auch ein bisschen den Weg frei für den Pass auf Sané. Und das fand ich total interessant, weil ich mich da gefragt habe, wo Gioamini da war. Weil der hätte Toni Kroos helfen müssen. Aber es waren auch so gut herausgespielte Tore. Ich meine, das eine eine super Einzelleistung. Sané war da nicht zu halten. Und Mondi ist halt Mondi. Carvajal halt gelb gesperrt. Hast ja halt vielleicht auch da gemerkt. Und das 2 zu 1 ist halt einfach auch so... Also natürlich klasse von Musiala, aber halt dieser Pass von Müller, der auch immer versucht hat, auf links zu spielen, egal ob Cain tiefgegangen ist. Das war total witzig. Also ich glaube, gegen Heidenheim wäre Cain verzweifelt und richtig sauer geworden. Gegen Real wusste er, naja, gut, das war anscheinend unser Plan. Dann mach halt weiter so, Thomas. Aber Müller wirklich hat aufgedreht und hat immer gleich zu Musiala geguckt oder zu Guerrero dann auch, der auch viel auf dem Flügel war.
Ich glaube, es war lustig, weil Groß ja teilweise so er hat sich ja fast mit in die dann Fünferkette fallen lassen. Der hat aus der Fünferkette so eine, ich habe aufgeschrieben, eine Fünfer-Halbkette gemacht. Und Germany stand dann schon meist teilweise fast 5 Meter höher als er. Ich glaube, deswegen, ich glaube, Groß hat teilweise Müller dann auch mal bei Ecken verteidigt und hat ihn auch einmal gut über den Haufen gecheckt oder was anderes rum. Also jetzt sind sie sich auf jeden Fall ein paar Mal begegnet dann noch.
Gut möglich. Auf jeden Fall. Toni Groß lässt sich da auffallen, ist da so manchmal auch ein bisschen libero Vorstopperrolle, dass es bewusst tiefer geht, um nicht ganz angelaufen zu werden, um in Ruhe den Pass spielen zu können, aber eben auch, um einfach hinten es noch enger zu machen, auch weil Werder rückt oft nach hinten. Also es ist schon oft drauf ausgelegt im Sinne von, ja, wir wagen jetzt noch ein bisschen ab. Wir haben jetzt nicht immer die 5 Mitspieler in der gegnerischen Hälfte. Es reicht, wenn wir 2 da vorne haben mit Bellingham und Vinicius und die anderen räumen hinten ein bisschen auf. Und dann wird einer vorne geschickt, was wie gesagt nicht unbedingt das ganz attraktive Traumfußball ist. Aber es reicht halt meistens zu den Ergebnissen, wenn man hinten da ein bisschen aufmerksam, konzentriert verteidigt mit viel Einsatz und da noch einem Anschlott, die an der Seite mit der Hand in der Hosentasche geht. Funktioniert halt doch immer.
Ach, er war auch einfach so entspannt, auch auf der Pressekonferenz danach.
Ich habe noch zwei Beobachtungen, weil ich die vorhin einmal angerissen habe. Und die muss ich unbedingt noch loswerden. Ich habe mir aufgeschrieben, weil du gerade vorhin auch gesagt hast, bei dem Freistuss dann fast die erste Chance. Das lag auch, ich habe hier geschrieben, 18. bis 38. Sané, wo? Komplett abgetaucht. Ich finde nämlich, dass der eigentlich kein gutes Spiel gemacht hat. Und dann gibt es diese Chance von groß in der zweiten Halbzeit, beim Stand von 0-1. Da verliert Sané vorne den Ball. Und dann, das war vorhin wirklich gemeint, der Rückwärtsbewegung. Sané zieht so leicht den Sprint an, trabt dann und schaltet dann aber 30 Meter vor dem eigenen Tor ab. Und verliert in der ganzen Situation 10 Meter auf Toni Groß im Umschaltspiel. Und wenn Groß den reinmacht, dann reden wir halt über das, dass Kim und Sané den Bayern das Spiel verloren haben. Und dann macht er direkt danach das Tor, nur Loll aufgeschrieben. Weil er sich ein großes Sané-Bashing ausholen wollte. Und dann macht er mit der Einzelaktion des Torens. Das ist dann das, was du als Offensivspieler hast, was du als Defensivspieler nicht hast. Aber diese eine Umschaltbewegung davor, die Nicht-Umschaltbewegung von ihm, wäre ausgeflippt, glaube ich.
Wobei da auch Vinicius gegen 3 Bayern den Ball so lange festmachen kann, bis er, ich glaube, auf Bellingham stecken kann. Und der verlagert dann auf Groß. Das stimmt schon mit Sané. Ich muss aber sagen, bei Sané muss man dann auch anfügen. Der war die komplette Halbzeit über auf dem Feld, weil er sich weiter warmhalten musste. Weil wenn er abkühlt, dann kehren die Schmerzen am Schambein zurück und dann kann er nicht mehr spielen. Das hat auch Thomas Tuchel danach gesagt. Er hat auch danach gesagt, er wird jetzt wieder geschont. Und dann hoffen wir, dass das fürs Rückspiel wieder reicht. Also sprich, es stimmt. Aber wenn jemand quasi unter Schmerzen spielt, dann merkst du das vielleicht genau in so einer Szene, wo du halt einen Sprint anziehen musst, bei dem du nicht gleich siehst, dass jetzt die Helden grätschen, sondern du musst ihn halt erstmal machen. Also vielleicht kann man ihn da in Schutz nehmen. Er spielt halt verletzt. Ich sehe schon, du kannst nicht so gut damit leben.
Nein, das ist okay. Einzelspieler-Bashing ist eigentlich eh nicht so meins. Aber das sind halt so zwei Sachen, die mir aufgefallen sind. Und jetzt im Vergleich zu zum Beispiel Adeyemi gestern. Aber ich hatte das mit der Verletzung tatsächlich gerade auch gar nicht im Kopf bei ihm.
Ja, das ist eben, dadurch, dass er in der Halbzeit rausgeblieben ist und dann auf der Pressekonferenz wurde Thomas Tuchel danach gefragt. Da hat er eben gesagt, wenn er abkühlt, dann kann er nicht mehr weiterspielen. Deswegen war er quasi draußen und hat quasi die 15 Minuten simuliert. Weil ihn nämlich ein Reporter gefragt hat, ja, der hat da die ganze Zeit diese Finte nach innen geübt. Hat er das etwa gemacht, um das 1 zu 1 zu erzielen? Und das war ja einfach nur, der wusste halt nicht, was für Übungen er noch machen soll. Der wollte da halt warm bleiben. Und das hat dann Thomas Tuchel auf eine nettere Art und Weise gesagt. So, bevor wir in eure Ligen gehen, Tipp, Nils, du darfst anfangen.
Ja, mein Herz sagt natürlich Real Madrid. Wegen Heimvorteil, wegen Personal, bessere Situation, weniger Ausfälle. Auch eigentlich bessere Formen und bessere Team kann mehr aushalten. Aber Tuchel hat, glaube ich, auch noch nie bei Real Madrid verloren. Also das müsste jetzt zum ersten Mal passieren. Deswegen rechne ich da schon noch, dass die Bayern da auch noch ein paar Optionen haben in der Hinterhand. Aber wie gesagt, ich glaube, von rein von der Motivation her, im Benabio, das wird schon einfach ein beeindruckendes Stadion. Das wird auch irgendwo sein Faktor haben. Wenn das Dach zu ist, ist es noch mal ein bisschen lauter. Da fühlen sich die Bayern-Spieler schon irgendwo mal, wie auf einem anderen Planeten in den Staaten, werden da schon auch staunen. Und wenn dann wirklich auch Vinicius wieder einfach seine Läufe macht, der hat jetzt schon wieder deutlich über 30 Torbeteiligungen in dieser Saison, spielt im Top-Jahr. Der wird da maximal motiviert sein. Wird schon schwer, Real Madrid zu schlagen. Deswegen ist mein Tipp schon, dass Real Madrid weiter kommt. Wie? Keine Ahnung, vielleicht Notfalls wieder Verlängerung. Wie gesagt, in den 90 Minuten gewinnt Real Madrid aktuell die Spiele nicht unbedingt in der Champions League. Aber es reicht irgendwie immer. Wenn es dann wieder ein schönes 5 zu 4 ist, mit ein paar Fehlentscheidungen, dann kann man auch da sagen, typisch Real Madrid wieder.
Ich finde es auch sehr schön, wie du davon ausgehst, dass Bayern-Spieler ins Stadion kommen und sich erst mal erstaunt umdrücken. Da sehe ich ja Conny Leiner, wie er mitten im Sprint stehen bleibt und nicht noch mal einen Ball abjagen.
Auch weil es Nils gerade gesagt hat mit den 3-4 Fehlentscheidungen, haben wir gar nicht darüber gesprochen. Es waren beide zwei Spiele mit sehr guter Schiedsrichterleistung. Ich habe sehr gerne Fußball geguckt, weil bei der UEFA bei bestimmten V-Sachen die Eingriffsschwelle des UEFA so hoch ist.
Und auch das Bemühen, keine gelben Karten zu geben. Vorhin bei Adeyemi habe ich mir das gedacht, weil er ihren Matzen helfen musste, der schon eine 19. Minute gelb sieht. Da dachte ich mir, das könnte jetzt was werden gegen Dembélé. Aber es wurden nur die richtig klaren Vs mit Gelb bewertet.
Auch halbtaktische nicht. Was ich auch voll in Ordnung finde. Wenn das deine Linie ist, deswegen waren auch alle... Ich glaube, bei Dortmund habe ich mal diesen Check von Sabitzer gegen Lucas Hernandez. Jetzt sehe ich in der Bundesliga acht von zehn Elfmeter. Nach zwei Minuten Videobeweis. Aber das waren zwei Schiedsrichter, die sich nicht in das Spiel mehr eingemischt haben, als sie es hätten tun müssen.
Jonathan Taylor und Thorpeen war das bei... Oder Thorpeen? Ich weiß es gar nicht.
Wir haben ja leider keine Franzosen hier.
Da bin ich völlig aufgeschmissen. Das seht ihr mal, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, weshalb es diese Runde braucht. Also, Real sagt Nils, was sagst du, Mario?
Ich glaube leider auch, dass das Finale Real PSG heißen wird.
Und Nils, setze auch auf PSG.
Na ja, ich habe eigentlich schon im Hinspiel auf PSG auf die typischen zwei Mbappé-Tore gesetzt. Aber mit der Energieleistung und dem bisschen Spielglück, dann ist es möglich. Aber man muss schon sehr mutig sein, da für den BVB zu tippen. Ich glaube auch einfach, dass der Druck bei PSG so groß ist. Ich war selbst mal bei einem Rückspiel in Paris dabei. Da hattest du das Gefühl, dass Altkiller Ify höchstpersönlich auf jeden Sitzplatz ein Bengalo verteilt hat. Da wird auch die Grundstimmung so sein. Wir machen alles und wir nutzen jeden Einfluss. Jetzt war sogar Sarkozy in Dortmund dabei. Du kannst dir nur ausmalen, was da ein Druck sein wird auf die Schiedsrichter. Also wird es irgendwie PSG machen, wie es schon in der Gruppenphase hier und da mit Glück war, dass sie weitergekommen sind. Also wird es auch da irgendwo PSG sich irgendwie durchsetzen.
Ich muss aber auch sagen, ich habe bislang alles mit deutschem Bezug, diese Europapokal-Saison falsch getippt. Ich liege gerne wieder falsch. Und bei PSG, ich glaube immer noch nicht, dass die titelreif sind. Also es könnte schon sein, dass dieser Druck, den du gerade beschrieben hast, dir jetzt schon im Halbfinale wieder bricht.
Hoffentlich. Aber das ist ja das Schöne.
Fußball, K.o. Spiele, Titmisse, wirklich.
Eben. Einfach angucken und genießen. Stimmt, das wollte ich noch sagen. Bayern gegen Real, hochintensives Spiel. Passquoten 94% zu 91%. Und als jemand, der erst vor ein paar Tagen Gladbach gegen Union sehen musste, kann ich euch sagen, liebe Leute, ich habe zu einem Kollegen von der Taz herzliche Grüße, habe ich gesagt, es ist, als würde man Augensalbe verwenden. Es hat so gut getan. Einfach so wenige Fehler. Es war richtig schön. Naja, also wir schauen es uns an, aber wir wollten eben dieses kleine Champions League-Segument machen. Jetzt wäre die Frage, Mario, wollen wir dann auch noch kurz auf italienische Europapokal-Teilnehmer blicken, die heute Abend antreten?
Man kann es ja ganz kurz machen.
Also für Roma, für alle Podcast-Hörenden?
Ja, stimmt. Die Roma gegen Leverkusen. Wird glaube ich ein sehr schwerer Gang für Bayern, den ja so ein bisschen auch die Kraft ausgeht. Aber die Roma ist jetzt auch tatsächlich, wenn sie jetzt die Mischung noch wieder mehr Mourinho drin hätten, glaube ich. Weil der Rossi ist schon auch mehr engagiert und nach vorne. Und das hat man zuletzt auch schon immer Gegentore schlucken müssen. Ich bin sehr gespannt darauf, wie sie das versuchen werden, das zu lösen. Sie haben aber Lukaku fehlt, aber dafür ist jetzt Tammy Abram wieder zurück. Der hat jetzt irgendwie auch ziemlich fast genau nach einem Jahr exakt sein erstes Tor wieder erzielt beim Spiel in Napoli, da wo sie 2-2 gespielt haben am Wochenende. Und wenn du dir das dann so anguckst, die Offensive mit dem Farrer, das wir ihn einmal untergebracht haben, Stefan El-Sharawi erlebt seinen fünften Frühling. Dabei ist er gerade auch erst Anfang 30, aber der ist für mich im Kopf auch schon ungefähr 40, weil er zwischendurch ja mal in China war. Und dann hast du halt die Baller, Tammy Abram, hinten so Leute wie Mancini, einen super guten Torwart gerade. Da hat der Mille Swilla, der ganz Junge, hat Rui Patricio abgelöst. So kurz vor dem Trainerwechsel war das sogar schon. Der gerade alles hält. Ich kann mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass es heute tatsächlich die erste Niederlage Leverkusens gibt in dieser Saison.
Und ich habe gelesen, Roma jetzt zum vierten Mal in Folge in einem europäischen Halbfinale. Das gleicht die Serie von Juventus Turin aus von 1963 bis 1967. Da dachte ich mir, holla, das hatte ich so nicht mehr auf dem Schirm. Letztes Jahr habe ich mitbekommen und vorher halt Conference League, aber schon beeindruckend.
Was Mourinho da auf jeden Fall geschafft hat, ist diese Art Gewinnermentalität zwischendurch. So Platz ist irgendwie einzuführen, das sah dann zwischenzeitlich sehr schlecht aus. Aber jetzt mit De Rossi, glaube ich, hat man die immer noch und spielt wieder ein bisschen mehr Fußball.
Mensch, dann kann doch Mourinho jetzt zum österreichischen Fußballverband und da dann als nächstes die Gewinnermentalität imbrachen. Verdichten sich alle Hinweise. Im Pressebereich waren sich alle jetzt plötzlich sehr einig mit 3 Franken. Aber im Pressebereich haben sie aber auch alle Witze darüber gemacht beim Arsenal-Spiel, dass Christian Dresen zwischen den Zeilen gesagt hat, dass er das erste Jahr nächste Woche verkünden wird in Nagelsmann. Da kann man nicht so viel drauf geben. Das war schon sehr nett. Aber es könnte ja auch in der Europa League, so wie in der Champions League, ein deutsches Finale möglich sein. Es ist in der Europa League ein italienisches Finale möglich. Atalanta spielt noch in Marseille heute Abend. Aus vielen Gründen heraus ein brisantes Aufeinandertreffen, glaube ich.
Ja, ich glaube das auch. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie sich da umschauen werden, aber ich glaube, Spiele in Marseille sind auch immer auf jeden Fall ein schwerer Gang für die Spiele.
Ja, die haben ja kein geschlossenes Dach, deswegen wird das ein Schock werden.
Wie Konrad Leimer.
Nee, da ist es vor allem einfach Atalanta, die jetzt auch noch ins Coppa Italia-Finale eingezogen sind. Die Ära unter Gasperini, die hatten ja auch in der Corona-Saison, wo sie so weit in die Champions League gegangen sind, dass es jetzt irgendwie kein Hot-Tech mehr ist, dass Atalanta ansiedlich Fußball spielt und es sich lohnen würde, die anzugucken. Aber die haben auch nochmal eine immense Weiterentwicklung gemacht. Das ist nicht mehr nur Vollgas-Fußball, aber es ist sehr, sehr körperlicher Fußball mit wirklich guten Kickern. Also ich glaube, es könnte auch ein bisschen augensalber werden für dich, wenn du den zuschaust. Vor allem haben sie einen Gianluca Scarmacca vorne in absoluter Top-Form. Ich bin gespannt, ob es den dann wieder in die Premier League zieht oder ob das halt einer ist, der nur in Italien funktioniert. Aber da funktioniert er gerade unfassbar gut. Cobb Maynard ist dahinter, der dann wahrscheinlich letztes Jahr leider nicht Champions League spielen wird mit Bergamo, sondern den wird es ziemlich sicher auf die Insel ziehen. Aber es ist so, nach vielen Jahren, jetzt diese Saison, wo glaube ich bei denen, ja, also entweder holt sich Gasparini jetzt einen Titel oder dann, könnte ich mir vorstellen, dann klappt es auch gar nicht mehr. Weil sie waren so oft nah dran. Und der Verein hat insgesamt halt erst einen Pokalsieg in den 60ern geholt, meine ich. Und da wird er auch immer wieder drauf angesprochen. Er ist auch ein ganz schöner Krantler. Hat er letztens irgendwie als idiotisch bezeichnet, ein Journalist, der gemeint hat, er ist dann unvollendet, wenn er keinen Titel holt. Ich glaube, das kannst du auch so nicht sagen, weil der hat da immens viel aufgebaut. Aber es wäre ihn schon zu wünschen. Und jetzt, nachdem sie da auch so souverän Liverpool ausgeschaltet haben, glaube ich, gehören die schon, ja, jetzt gegen, also im Marseille sehe ich sie als Clan-Favoriten. Ohne die Liga großartig zu verfolgen. Ich weiß nicht, da funktioniert ja Aubameyang wieder anscheinend. Aber wir haben super viele spannende Spieler. Also hinten Skalvini, den ganz jungen, den sehen wir vielleicht bei der Europameisterschaft auch noch. Wir haben Ruggieri, auch ein junger Schienenspieler links.
Aber es ist ja die einzige Chance noch für Atalanta auf die Champions League, weil du gerade gesagt hast, wird nicht nächste Saison mit Atalanta Champions League spielen, dachte ich mir schon, ah, da ist der Europa League-Sieg schon eingepreist. Weil das ist ja ganz interessant. Also die Roma hat theoretisch noch Chancen, 4 Punkte Rückstand aktuell auf Bologna. Man hat ja auch in den Restminuten des nachgeholtem Spiels noch tatsächlich ein Tor erzielen können, dass das noch zu einem Sieg wurde. Also das war die Ivan and Dika-Geschichte, die wir in der letzten Liga-Tour hier ausführlich besprochen haben. Aber Atalanta ist im Grunde mit 6 Punkten Rückstand. Da muss man ja eher gucken, dass man nicht noch von hinten den Druck von Lazio bekommt.
Aber Italien hat auch einen fünften Platz.
Italien bekommt... Ach so. Das heißt, wenn sie zwei Punkte auf Rom aufholen, richtig fernachsend.
Und sie haben noch ein Spiel weniger.
Stimmt, es könnten ja sogar sechs Champions-League-Teilnehmer werden. Das war ja das, was ich gelesen habe. Wenn einer von denen nämlich die Europa League gewinnt... Ah, ja, okay, gut.
Und sie haben tatsächlich noch ein Spiel weniger, weil es ist ein Ligaspiel gegen die Fiorentina. Da gibt es immer noch keinen Termin. Das war an dem Wochenende, wo da der Besitzer verstorben war.
Ja, und wo es ja jetzt die Theorie gibt, dass das eventuell erst nach der Saison gespielt werden kann. Also, wenn quasi der 38. Spieltag schon vorbei ist, weil Atalanta jetzt noch im Halbfinale steht, was ja auch sehr kurios wäre, dass dann quasi viele Vereine gar nicht wüssten. Stimmt, Entschuldigung, ja, dann haben sie natürlich...
Vor allem in der einen Woche vor dem letzten Spieltag spielt Atalanta nämlich das Pokalfinale. Das ist nämlich anders als in Deutschland. Das ist, glaube ich, am 15. Mai schon. Also das ist auch dazwischen, wo man dann auch keine Luft mehr hätte, irgendwie da in der Woche was reinzuschieben.
Ach, das ist ja verrückt. Oh Mensch, ey, da können wir uns drauf freuen. Aber dann ist ja Bologna schon so gut wie drin.
Geil!
Ich freue mich so.
Müssen wir mit dem Zug mal hinfahren. Kannst du doch. München-Osten nach Bologna gibt es einen Zug.
Du, guter Freund, ich glaube uns beiden bekannt. Er hatte schon mehrmals zu mir gesagt, machen wir mal einen Kurzurlaub in Bologna. Aber dann machen wir es. Dann machen wir es wirklich. Sehr gut. Und dann haben wir ja auch noch Conference League. Vielleicht auch noch ganz kurz. Müssen wir jetzt ja nicht ins Detail hineingehen. Aber Florenz gegen Brügge könnte ja auch noch ins Finale einziehen. Also Italien wirklich nicht zufällig diesen 5. Champions League-Platz geholt.
Ja, also die Fiorentiner muss so ein bisschen über den Pokal, so ein bisschen wie Dortmund über die Pokalwettbewerbe diese Saison wieder gut machen, weil die haben sich in der Liga zwischenzeitlich so eine krasse Durchhänger geleistet, weil sie sich vor allem auch vorne ganz schwer getan haben, Tore zu erzielen. Aber ich glaube, Brügge, ehrlicherweise, der belgische Fußball, ich kann den vom Niveau schlecht einschätzen, aber Brügge macht diese Saison, ein, zwei Mal habe ich die gesehen, sind schon auch nicht so schlecht. Also das würde ich, glaube ich, als 50-50-Ding einordnen.
Ja, vor allem zu Hause hat, glaube ich, Brügge sehr, sehr gut gespielt. Rückspiel dann ja am Mittwoch nächste Woche schon. Also da schauen wir mal, was die italienischen Vertreter machen. Jetzt gucken wir aber noch kurz in eure Ligen rein. Nils, du möchtest mit uns unter anderem über Almeria sprechen. Für die ist die Saison mehr oder weniger vorbei.
Ja, das ist eigentlich schon länger, aber jetzt ist es dann endgültig passiert. Am fünftletzten Spieltag war es passiert, der Abstieg besiegelt ihr dritter innerhalb von 13 Jahren. Viel mehr ging auch nicht, weil sie früher noch nie in der ersten Liga gespielt haben. Das ist der früheste Abstieg seit Elche letztes Jahr und seit Malaga 2008. Also nur um das ein bisschen einzuordnen für euch. Almeria seit dem fünften Spieltag, Tabellenletzter, ich glaube nicht mal Darmstadt ist so lange, hat so lange die rote Laterne in der Hand. Deswegen ist das ein historisch schwacher Abstieg, weil Almeria auch sehr sauer übergreifend 31 Spieltage ohne Sieg war. Neuer La Liga-Rekord. Sie haben von ihren jetzt 17 Heimspielen in dieser Saison noch immer keines gewonnen. Mittlerweile gab es mal einen Sieg mit dem dritten Trainer, hat gleich mal beim Einstand auf Las Palmas gewonnen, Auswärtssieg halt. Aber das war es auch so ziemlich. Also Almeria steht eigentlich für Finanzkraft, im Sinne von da ist ein Scheich im Hintergrund und der Aufstieg damals war auch nicht ganz unverdient. Sie hatten dann ein erstes ganz okayes Jahr in La Liga unter Trainer Rubi, aber der ist im Sommer dann freiwillig gegangen und jetzt, wie gesagt, hat schon drei Trainer in dieser Saison und da merkst du einfach, dass das eine ziemlich zusammengewürfelte Truppe ist. Die haben weit über 30 Spieler eingesetzt in dieser Saison. Keiner hat mehr als zehn Torbeteiligungen, also der beste Torjäger Sergio Arribas kam aus Real Madrids Nachwuchs mit sechs Treffern. Da ist, wie gesagt, eigentlich auch ganz gute Einzelspieler, auch Luis Suárez, der Colombianer vorne, hat viele Abschlüsse, aber irgendwie sie kriegen diese PS überhaupt nicht auf die Straße. Sie sind eigentlich die Mannschaft mit den acht meisten Abschlüssen in der Liga, aber hinten komplett fahrig, die Schießbude der Liga und vorne sogar nicht richtig griffig, weil viele Einzelakteure, es funktioniert nicht zusammen, wenn einer in einer guten Position ist, sucht er lieber selbst den Abschluss oder wählt immer eher tendenziell die schlechte Entscheidung. Da es selten den Eindruck gab, dass da wirklich eine gute zusammen funktionierende Mannschaft auf dem Platz steht, auch wenn sie natürlich Pech hatten, nicht nur in Benabio, auch gegen die anderen großen Teams. Da waren sie dann irgendwie doch mal motivierter. Da haben auch Athleti Barca ein bisschen geärgert. Aber es hat halt bisher erst zu einem Sieg gereicht. Und deswegen ist das ein ziemlich verdienter Abstieg.
Ich glaube, ehrlich gesagt, da kann man nichts hinzufügen. Wir haben es ja auch schon mal hier thematisiert in der Ligatur, dass es nicht so gut läuft bei Almeria und ein Sieg. Das ist doch auch eine Saison, wo du als Fan sagst, komm bitte, lass uns in die 2. Liga einfach mal wieder ein Spiel gewinnen. Also das macht dir auch wirklich keinen Spaß. Und bei Almeria muss man ja nicht befürchten, dass sie in die finanzielle Bedeutungslosigkeit abgleiten. Weil, du hast es ja gesagt, da ist ja Investorengeld dahinter. Aber ihr seht, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, man kann selbst mit Investoren absteigen. Ich meine, ich wohne in Giesing, ich hatte das immer hier klar vor Augen. Aber für euch würde ich das nochmal sagen.
Was würde da Fabian Pakulat jetzt sagen aus Malaga?
Ich glaube, der hat ausgemacht, weil das war nicht die Malaga-Erwähnung, die du vorhin genannt hast, mit schlechtester Absteiger seit, die er sich gewünscht hätte. Da war doch was. Es kann nicht jeden Tag Okasaki Day sein. Das war doch damals die Inhaltung, glaube ich, oder? 2019. Das ist also Almeria. Und wir haben auch noch ein Thema aus der Serie A. Und zwar Fabio Cannavaro. Der ist wieder da. Du hast es einfach nur so geschrieben bei uns im Chat. Und dann musste ich gleich googeln, weil ich hatte es nicht mitbekommen. Bringen auch alle Hörerinnen und Hörer auf Stand. In welcher Funktion und wo ist er wieder zu sehen?
Seine zweite Trainerstation in Italien, die erste in der Serie A. Und er hat Udinese-Kalsche übernommen, die mitten im Abstiegskampf stecken. Weil du gerade vorhin dieses Spiel Udinese-Roma angesprochen hast. Diese verbleibenden 21 Minuten, die dort nachgeholt werden mussten, waren sein erstes Spiel.
Ach echt? Ach das ist ja super unnützes Wissen.
Ja, das heißt sozusagen, er ist, er hat sein erstes Spiel mit der Aufstellung gespielt müssen, die noch sein Vorgänger da aufgestellt hatte. Weil der sozusagen entlassen worden ist davor, als sie gegen Hellas auch Abstiegskandidaten 0 zu 1 verloren hatten. Und sein erstes richtiges Spiel über 90 Minuten, man muss sagen, er hat sonst auch systematisch nicht ganz so viel geändert, hat er jetzt gegen Bologna bestritten und einen Punkt geholt. Was ein starkes Stück ist, also sie haben nach Führung und Bologna in Unterzahl noch zwei Punkte abgegeben, aber trotzdem gegen Bologna, du hast ja gerade vorhin dich schon drüber gefreut, und Champions League-Kandidaten vermutlich nächstes Jahr auch Champions League-Team. Da er da mal einen Punkt zu holen, ist aller Ehren wert. Ich glaube, es wird trotzdem ein ganz, ganz schwerer Gang, und ich kann ihn sehr schwer als Trainer einschätzen. Also der hat den natürlich ganz üblichen Werdegang, dass er nach seiner Karriere, die er auch schon in den Emiraten hat ausklingen lassen, da noch als Berater gearbeitet. Dann da als Trainer, hat er da sehr gute Punkte geschnitten. Ich weiß immer nicht, was. Dann war er in China. Der war kurz zwischenseitig sogar für zwei Spiele Inter-Riemsk-Trainer in China, bei der Nationalmannschaft. Die andere Station in Italien war Benevento. Da hatte er, als die aus der Serie A gestiegen waren, nach sieben Spielen übernommen in der Serie B, weil es da nicht lief. Und ist da dann aber auch vor Saisonende wieder gegangen worden, weil er drei Spiele gewonnen hat. Sieben Unentschieden, sieben Niederlagen. Ich glaube, das ist kein zweiter Thiago Mota und auch kein zweiter Daniele de Rossi. Und wenn man sich mal den Tabellen...
Eher so Stefan Öfenberg, SC Paderborn.
Ob es ganz so schlimm wird, hoffe ich für ihn nicht. Aber es ist schon... Also ich habe mit Marius drüber gesprochen gehabt und meinte, dass es kann schon so auch laufen, dass er sich da ist, 2. Station in Italien, und wenn das schief geht, schon komplett verbrannt ist. Also klar hat er einen großen Namen, aber er steht jetzt mit Udinese gerade auf dem ersten Abstiegsplatz mit 29 Zählern. Dahinter ist noch Sassu Olu mit 26. Salernitana ist abgestiegen jetzt seit dem letzten Wochenende mit 15 Punkten. Und vor Udinese sind... Also 2 sind es Punkte Rückstand aufs rettende Ufer. Und da sind 3 Teams mit 31 Punkten. Das sind Empoli, Fro Sinone, Hellas. Davor mit 32 Kaljari und Lecce auf 13 mit 36 ist eigentlich schon gesichert. Also es ist super eng. Aber sie spielen jetzt als nächstes gegen Napoli. Und dann kommen lauter direkte Gegner zu Lecce. Wie gesagt zwar gerettet, aber dann Empoli und am Schluss Fro Sinone. Das kann schon gut gehen. Muss es aber auch nicht. Und dann bist du halt bei Benevento im kleinen Verein gescheitert. Und bei Udinese, wir erinnern uns noch irgendwie alle an die, die Natales und so, die hatten richtig gute Zeiten. Die gehören ja der Familie Pozzo. Da gab es ja auch immer diese Spielertransfers mit Wartford, denen das auch gehört. Und die haben es ja geschafft, tatsächlich ihre super spannende Fußball-Franchise mit tollem Scouting, datenbasiert. Das waren da zwischenzeitlich so fortschrittlich unterwegs. Die fahren das da gerade. Ich glaube, Wartford geht sie auch nicht so gut. Also die fahren da gerade alles an die Wand. Und wenn er dann da der Busfahrer ist, der das dann schlussendlich noch mit an die Wand fährt, glaube ich, das wird ihm für seine Trainerlaufbahn nicht gut tun. Ich weiß aber auch nicht, wie wichtig ihm das wirklich ist.
Ja, also, wenn man mal Berater war, dann, also, wir müssen uns, glaube ich, finanziell keine Sorgen um ihn machen. Aber es ist natürlich interessant. Aber die direkten Duelle, wer weiß schon. Und Watford tatsächlich Rang 14 in der Championship. Und da haben wir ja 24 Plätze. Also, das ist die graue Maus. Haben in 45 Spielen 17 Unentschieden geholt. Das zieht jetzt nicht. Also, nach einem Ausstieg sieht es nicht aus.
Oh, apropos Aufstieg. Das noch der Vollständigkeit halber. Palma ist seit gestern wieder zurück in der Serie A. Will ich natürlich, vielleicht schaffst du ja Marios demnächst mal wieder her. Ich will ihm ja als Palma-Fan das hier nicht wegnehmen. Aber der Vollständigkeit halber. Die Serie B hat nämlich am 1. Mai einen Spieltag durchgezogen. Und durch einen Punkt in Bari, weil Venedig verloren hat, ist Palma durch. Wahrscheinlich folgt ihnen Como.
Da haben wir doch mehrere Ausflugsziele gleich, Mario.
Meine Familie freut sich sehr auf den Urlaub und die ganzen Playoffs Serie B und Serie C. Das ist Wahnsinn. Aber das bedeutet, da ist noch in den Juni hinein in vielen kleinen Ortschaften auch. Überall da, wo wir sind, werden da Fußballspiele anstehen.
Oh nein.
Und zufällig werden wir da Tagesausflüge hin machen.
Ach du, das ist so schön. Das sind die Rasen von Gäste. Ich hatte auch mal jemanden hier, der gesagt hat, seine Familie sagt er das nicht, aber er würde immer den Urlaub in die Nähe von Trainingslagern legen. Und dann frage ich ihn, ja, aber fährst du denn da auch hin? Ja klar, da bin ich dann den ganzen Tag nicht so. Ja, und du glaubst, deine Familie merkt das nicht? Wir sind alle etwas besonders in dieser Hinsicht, glaube ich. Und besonders ist auch Viareal. Die sind besonders in Form, besonders gut in Form. Aus den letzten sechs Spielen vier Siege, eine Niederlage, ein Unentschieden. Was geht da noch für Viareal?
Nicht unbedingt besonders als Urlaubsort, auch wenn es in der Region Valencia ist. Also dann fahrt lieber nach Valencia. Viareal ist mittlerweile so ein bisschen das Team der Stunde. Ich habe so noch eine positive Sache aus der Liga gesucht. Sie machen jetzt noch ein bisschen den Kampf um Platz 7. Spannend stehen da aktuell vier Punkte hinter Betis auf Rang 9. Dazwischen ist noch der FC Valencia. Die betteln sich gerade so und Viareal da eben jetzt wieder gut drauf, nachdem sie auch den Saisonstart ziemlich verpatzt hatten. Sie waren in der Hinrunden-Tabelle nur 13. jetzt in der Rückrunde hinter Barca und Real so gesehen die drittbeste Mannschaft. Nachdem sie eben im Sommer einen ziemlichen Ausverkauf hatten, also Nico Jackson ging nach Chelsea, Paul Torres ein sehr wichtiger Abgang oder sehr schlimmer Abgang in der Abwehr gewesen, zu Kuwait, nach Mailand und so weiter. Da sind schon einige wichtige Spiele gegangen. Und jetzt mittlerweile hat sich die Mannschaft klar gefangen. Alexander Sirloot macht vorne viele Tore. Alex Baena ist mit 12 Vorlagen der beste Vorlagengeber der Liga mittlerweile. Er hat jetzt einen Assist-Hat-Trick beim 3-0-Sieg gegen Raio. Also da macht jetzt aktuell neu Coach Marcelino, kam auch erst unter der Saison, macht da sehr viel richtig und gut. Und bestimmt hier und da muss er noch ein bisschen an seiner Defensive arbeiten, weil Villarreal die Mannschaft ist, die die meisten Abschlüsse in der Liga kassiert, ohne jetzt die Schießbude der Liga zu sein. Aber da merkst du schon, dass es ein bisschen, es wird mehr auf ältere gesetzt jetzt. Raul Albillol spielt immer noch, aber der Gute wie Paul Torres müssen gehen. Und ja, jetzt ist man irgendwo wieder in Schlagdistanz zum Europapokal. Dass man die Europa League selbst gewonnen hat, ist ja jetzt auch schon wieder 2, 3 Jahre her und Champions League-Halbfinale danach. Aber sie sind wieder ein bisschen da, obwohl es jetzt auch gegen Marseille die Blamage gab, selbst in der Europa League, oder was, die Conference League, Europa League natürlich. Aber in der Liga läuft es da jetzt besser, sieht einfach wieder gut aus. Und das auch dank einiger ganz guter Akteure, wie Sir Loth, wie Alex Baena.
Ja, also dritter der Rückrundentabelle. Das ist natürlich wirklich ordentlich. Und glaubst du, dass da in dieser Saison dann noch was geht? Ich traue mich jetzt nicht mehr, hier von der WhoScore-Tabelle abzuleiten, wer sich international qualifiziert, weil die mich so bei der Serie A am Stich gelassen hat.
Ich sehe jetzt Betty-San Valencia noch nicht so gefestigt, als dass die sicher vor Villareal bleiben werden. Und da eben aktuell die Form für Villareal spricht, ist da durchaus noch was möglich. Wir haben wie gesagt noch fünf Spieltage in La Liga. Und da sind ja vier Punkte Rückstand auf Platz 7, sind ja absolut möglich. Aber das wäre dann auch nur der Conference League-Platz. Also Villareal wird dann gerade aktuell 6. nur. Da, glaube ich, wird sich hier und da zumindest der Kampf um Platz 6 spannender als Platz 1 oder auf der letzten Platz, wo jetzt schon die Entscheidungen quasi gefallen sind. Deswegen schöpft man als La Liga-Expert, La Liga-Fan so ein bisschen. Dann schaut man so auf die Plätze und so, ah, da ist ja doch noch ein bisschen enger, da geht es darum was. Weil jetzt auch die Champions League-Ränge sind fast entschieden. Da hat Atletico quasi einen Kampf um Platz 4 gegen Atletik für sich entschieden. Aber Villareal schreibt gerade ein bisschen wieder ganz gute Geschichten, nachdem es eben auch im Sommer da diesen Ausverkauf gab, haben wir auch gefühlt einen Transferplus von über 100 Millionen gemacht. Also wir machen jetzt mal ein bisschen Geld mit einer Mannschaft, die zuletzt Erfolg hatte und dann wurde gar nicht so viel geholt, aber es sieht jetzt wieder besser aus.
Aber das ist tatsächlich gerade ein Thema bei der Liga. Also in der Serie A haben wir sowohl Champions League, als auch Europa League, als auch Abstieg noch total spannend. Bundesligasituationen kennen wir. In La Liga Abstieg, Kadez, 5 Punkte Rückstand auf Celta Vigo. Der Theorie nach geht da noch was, aber Form zeigt jetzt auch nicht unbedingt nach oben, würde ich sagen. Und oben hast du es ja gerade schon erklärt. Aber ganz so extrem war es in den letzten Jahren doch nicht, dass es fünf Spieltage vor Schluss so wenige spannende Tabellenregionen noch gibt, oder?
Ich würde schon erst mal sagen, dass die drei wahrscheinlichen Absteiger, Granada auch so gut wie Veck und Cardis, schon die drei schwächsten Absteiger der letzten Jahre sind. Also dass du da schon auch einen gewissen Abstand hast zu den Plätzen davor. Das ist bei Real Madrid jetzt auch schon. Die Meisterschaftsentscheidung kann es theoretisch erst am übernächsten Spieltag geben, ist aber dann auch nicht ganz so eng wie getippt, weil einfach auch Barca hier und da Probleme hatte in dieser Saison. Und deswegen, ja, gab es schon mal gefühlt spannendere Saisons. Das spiegelt sich auch vielleicht ein bisschen im Europapokal abschneidender Spanier wieder, wo ja jetzt Real Madrid die einzige verbleibende Mannschaft noch ist, auch wenn es im Viertelfinale da für drei Champions League-Teilnehmer gab. Aber ich hatte angedeutet, hier via Real Blamage gegen Marseille und auch in Betis hatte sie sich, glaube ich, früher in der Conference League verabschiedet. Sevilla als Vierter ausgeschieden in der Gruppenphase, also da die Planung mit Platz 3 haben sie diesmal komplett vergeigt. Und deswegen war das jetzt auch letztes Jahr schon, hat glaube ich Sevillas Europa-League-Sieg über einiges wegkaschiert. Real Madrid immerhin noch Champions League-Halbfinale gewesen, wie er immer gefühlt. Aber das ist jetzt schon die Tendenz, geht eher nach unten im internationalen Vergleich bei La Liga. Da scheint auch die Serie A aktuell vielleicht einiges besser zu machen.
Und das muss ja am Salary Cap liegen, den ja jetzt die Premier League auch einführen wollen würde, aber die reichen Vereine, wer hätte das gedacht, stimmen dagegen und Manchester United, weil sie sagen, da können wir ja international nicht mehr mithalten. Es ist so lustig.
Kann die Bundesliga ja auch nicht ohne Investor, dachte ich.
Die Bundesliga? Unmöglich. Aber ich habe es hier immer gesagt, schminkt euch den fünften Champions League-Platz ab und wie immer habe ich recht behalten, liebe Leute. Aber gut, das sind ja Momentaufnahmen, die wir aber genau beobachten. Und genauer werde ich jetzt auch beobachten, wen ihr eure Awards verleiht. Wir wollen nach MVP, Anson Hero und Moment des Spieltags in euren Ligen führen. Mario, du darfst mal anfangen. Wer ist denn dein MVP?
Hakan Salanolu hat zwei Tore erzielt am Wochenende. Hinter war er schon Meister. Das war sozusagen der Tag der Busparade, wo sie noch mal Torino 2-0 geschlagen haben. Auch kein leichter Gegner. Er hat jetzt so viele Tore wie zuletzt. Ein Mittelfeldspieler im Inter-Trikot war Lothar Matthäus Anfang der 90er. Ich glaube, das ist auch über die gesamte Saison von Christian und Marius wahrscheinlich immer wieder gesagt worden. Aber was der für eine Entwicklung genommen hat und wie wichtig der für die Meisterschaft Inters war. Und jetzt dann eben auch noch mal am vergangenen Spieltag mit zwei Toren. Deswegen macht man nicht viel falsch mit, wenn man gerade aktuell Hakan Sharanullu sagt.
Aber absolut. Und ich bin natürlich auch sehr froh, dass hier in der Ligatur der Meistertitel im Derby Milano gecalled wurde. Und das muss ja auch wirklich ganz fantastisch gewesen sein. Ich hatte mit Frauenbundesliga zu tun, deswegen konnte ich es leider nicht live sehen. Aber ich will nicht verhehlen, während ich die Sendung dann fertig gemacht habe irgendwann Nacht, vielleicht lief da noch mal das Spiel im Real Life auf einem zweiten Bildschirm. Und vielleicht habe ich zwischendurch auch mal nicht Shownotes gemacht, sondern da nur hingeguckt. Das war schon, ja, das ist irgendwie schön, wenn solche Spiele dann auch halten, was man sich von ihnen verspricht. Das war schon was Besonderes. Nils, dein Anzang Hero bitte. Entschuldigung, ne, MVP, wir sind ja beim MVP. Meine Güte, was ist denn mit mir los?
Ich kann doch erst den MVP machen, machen wir alles der Ordnung.
Ich habe mich an die Reihenfolge gehalten, die du mir geschickt hast, ohne nachzudenken. Alles gut, MVP bitte.
Dann war es auch mein Fehler, ja. Ich muss jetzt eine Doppelerwähnung, oder den hatte ich eben schon kurz erwähnt, aber ich finde, Alexander Sirloot ist aktuell der Spieler, der so mit am meisten überperformt oder am meisten aus seinen Chancen rausholt. Ich glaube nur, Jude Bellingham hat noch einen höheren XG in der Liga mit plus sechs, aber Sirloot hat auch irgendwie fünf Tore mehr als erwartet. Der hat schon zwei richtig gute Jahre bei Real Sociedad hinter sich und hat jetzt diese Torbeteiligungsanzahl, 25 Stück, jetzt auch schon fast mit Villarreal in seiner Debüt-Saison ausgeglichen. Also ist da auch ein sehr, sehr wichtiger Spieler gemeinsam mit Gérard Moreno da, Doppelsturm und das obwohl jetzt Sirloot gar nicht die 11 Meter schießen darf, das ist Chefsache Moreno. Dani Parejo also spielt da eine Top-Saison, hat aus den letzten acht Spieltagen auch acht Tore rausgeholt und ist da eben, wie gesagt, so ein bisschen aktuell die Lebensversicherung. Nicht nur, dass er überperformt, sondern einfach auch da ein absoluter Fixpunkt im Angriff ist. So ein 1, 90 Meter Mann gibt es jetzt auch nicht so auf einer Liga, das wird dann schon auch ganz gut genutzt und eben all diese guten Zahlen, ohne dass er jetzt der klare Standardschütze ist, finde ich schon beeindruckend und dadurch, dass man ihn ja ein bisschen noch aus der Bundesliga erkennt, finde ich ihn da sehr erwähnenswert.
17 Treffer hat er jetzt eben in seinen bisherigen 25 Spielen und durfte damit ja auch in der Torjägerliste relativ weit vorne sein. Rang 3 hinter Artem Dovbek. Ach ja, den haben wir hier auch schon häufiger erwähnt von Girona und einem gewissen Jude Bellingham. Also das läuft wirklich sehr gut. Stimmt, genau, sie teilen sich ja. Meine Güte, heute lassen mich alle Webseiten im Stich. Warum wird denn das hier als Platz 3 ausgewiesen? Nee, die Seite war es nicht. Aber gut, also mein Unsung Hero ist nicht meine persönliche Vorbereitung auf diese Sendung hier. Nils, mach doch dann gleich mit deinem Unsung Hero weiter, wenn ich das eh schon angekündigt habe.
Unsung ist so der Begriff, aber ganz so unbesungen ist er gar nicht speziell. Türkische Fans schreien seinen Namen gerne raus. Es ist der lachende Name, es ist Ada Güler. Der hätte auch der Moment des Spieltags sein können, denn er hat jetzt in seinem La Liga-Debüt direkt mal auch getroffen. Das war der 1-0-Sieg gegen Real Sociedad von Real Madrid. Schöne Kombination. Chur Meni raus auf Coverhalt, er direkt in den Strafraum und an eine Sküle. Er läuft ein. Das war natürlich pures Talent und Wille. Nein, das war ja Stadion-Tag.
Mentalität was bitte.
Mentalität natürlich. Er zeigt mittlerweile, dass er das Talent absolut hat, wie sich die Mannschaft für ihn gefreut hat, weil alle wissen, er hat es eigentlich so drauf. Und im Training geht jeder Schuss in den Winkel. Aber er kann es halt noch nicht so zeigen, weil Carlo Ancelotti ihn nicht so einsetzt. Wir reden da über 166 Pflichtspielminuten, jetzt schon zwei Treffer. Dazu kommt noch ein herausgeholter Elfmeter, zwei Aluminium-Treffer. Also so lesen sich die Statistiken schon ganz gut. Und es war einfach ein schöner Moment, dass da, wie sich die Mannschaft mit ihm gefreut hat, dass auch der, er jetzt Güller, mal wieder lachen konnte, steht ja sein Name dafür. Deswegen ist er da so ein bisschen unbesungen, vielleicht bei neutralen Fans, aber auch wenn, wie gesagt, türkische Fans den Namen schon ganz gerne in den Mund nehmen.
Aber glaubst du denn, also Güller ist ja eines der größten türkischen Talente, und es war schon interessant, dass er jetzt zu dieser Saison zur Real gewechselt ist. Glaubst du, der wird seine Rolle finden, wenn eben dieses Mittelfeld irgendwann dann doch mal verjüngt werden muss, weil er ist ja schon offensives Mittelfeld, so seine Position?
Ja, und da er jetzt auch speziell im Sommer nicht nur Endricchi aus Brasilien kommen wird, gut, Mittelstürmer, aber dann wahrscheinlich auch dieser eine von PSG, wird schon da die Konkurrenz nicht unbedingt kleiner, aber ich glaube einfach, dass er mit seinen 19 Jahren schon einerseits die Geduld hat und auch weiß, worauf es drauf ankommt bei Real Madrid. Das hat nicht jeder, und trotzdem hat ein Kubo ja seinen Platz gefunden, hat auch ein Martin Oedegaard seinen Platz gefunden, die vielleicht, wie gesagt, ein bisschen wenig Geduld hatten bei Real Madrid, aber dafür Andernorts Geduld. Ich glaube, Ada Güller weiß schon, dass er da die Geduld haben muss, bekommt das auch von seinen Mitspielern eingeredet, eingeträgt hat, will sich auch gar nicht vielleicht verleihen lassen im Sommer. Und er hatte jetzt auch die Hinrunde komplett verletzungsbedingt verpasst, deswegen ist dieser Zug für Real Madrid auch so ein bisschen abgefahren. Aber jetzt dann wird er, glaube ich, den Neustart wagen im Sommer und wie gesagt, er ist ja voll integriert, spricht auch schon Spanisch, hat er viel gelernt. Er sendet schon viele positive Signale, um zu bleiben, um auch von Ancelotti häufiger eingesetzt zu werden, zumindest dann in der kommenden Saison. Aber dadurch, dass jetzt auch die Liga quasi wie laufen ist noch für Spieltage, wird er da jetzt noch mehr zu Einsatzzeiten kommen.
Sehr, sehr spannend. Und dann schauen wir uns noch den Anzang Hero in der Serie A an, Mario.
Ja, ich habe mich mal für einen Ersatztorwart entschieden, der ganz spontan einspringen musste, Marco Sportiello, beim Topspiel Juve gegen Milan. Mike Mignot hat sich beim Aufwärmen verletzt. Und dann, wir waren gerade bei Spielen, die versprechen, was sie halten. Ehrlicherweise war es hier auch so, aber weil ich mir versprochen hatte, dass es ein richtiger Trex-Kick wird. Also Juve unter Max Allegri. Und Milan unter Stefano Pioli. Es ist gerade nicht mehr das, was es mal war. Oder bei Max Allegri ist es genau das, was es immer war. Ja, aber im Endeffekt hatte Juve extrem viele gute Chancen hinten raus noch. Marcos Portiello hat alles gehalten. Sieben Abschlüsse aufs Tor bekommen. Großchancen gehalten. Und hat damit Milan so gut wie sicher die Vizemeisterschaft eingetütet, weil es weiterhin jetzt fünf Punkte vor Juve sind. Und ich glaube, das ist ein kleiner Punkt, mit dem man sich dann vielleicht am Ende doch noch anfreunden kann. Das ist so, wo klar Inter dann beim Derby-Meister wird oder so. Aber ist es ehrlicherweise so viel Auf- und Ab- und Verletzung und was auch immer. Und auch bei Milan hat nicht immer alles funktioniert. Das glaube ich, dann kann man auch Not vorziehen, dass sie dann in der Saison Zweiter werden. Und er hat jetzt dann in dem Spieltag ganz großen Anteil dran gehabt.
Ersatztorhüter, die in eine Rolle spielen, das liest man doch immer wieder gerne und sieht man auch gerne. Und was war dein Moment des Spieltags?
Ja, kann man direkt dann daran anschließen. Also du hattest es schon angesprochen. Natürlich das Derby am Spieltag davor, das die Meisterschaft, die 20. für Inter, bedeutet hat und darauf aufbauend jetzt am letzten Spieltag die Busparade und Mailand, also das war eine Meisterfeier, wie sie sein sollte. Und das lustige, wenn du gesagt hast, du hast auch noch ein bisschen ReLive des Derbys geschaut, da ging es da hinten raus auch nochmal richtig hoch her. Und die Kollegen Dumfries und Tera Hernandez, die mochten sich schon immer sehr, sehr gerne. Und bei der Busparade ist auf einmal so ein Doppelhalter von Fans an Dumfries auf den Bus hochgegeben worden. Und er hat das kurz angeguckt und dann auch voller Imprunst hochgezeigt und da ist Denzel Dumfries, der einen Hund an der Leine führt. Und dieser Hund trägt das Gesicht von Tera Hernandez. Das ist nah an der Kürtellinie dran, finde ich. Das ist vielleicht schon einen Tick drunter. Aber ich finde, das darf einmal erlaubt sein im Jahr. Und was ich jetzt ganz lustig fand, das ist bestimmt KI oder so, die das gemacht hat. Aber ich habe in sozialen Netzwerken kleine Lego-Sets gesehen, wo ein Dummfriesmännchen, das ein Tera Hernandez-Männchen als Hund an der Leine führt. Das hat alles vereint, was sich in der Stadt entladen hat. Und ich finde es aus der Warte auch in Ordnung, weil die Milan und die Interfans ja schon seit Jahren einen Friedenspakt haben. Obwohl die Rivalität so groß ist, wird sich ja sonst zwischen denen vereinigt. Und dann kann man mal beide Augen zudrücken, wenn auch ein leicht desplizierter, destipierlicher, oh Gott. Ihr wisst, was ich meine. Wenn ein Spieler ein Plakat hochhalten würde, wo er sonst wahrscheinlich, da könnte man auch drüber reden, ob er dafür eine Sperre bekommen muss oder bestraft werden muss. Aber man muss, glaube ich, nicht alles immer vor das Sportgericht ziehen. Da sind tatsächlich in Italien in den letzten Jahren schon schlimmere Sachen, die nicht geahndet worden sind, gemacht worden.
Unter anderem deswegen ist es ja nach allem, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, auch zu diesem Friedenspakt zwischen Milan und Interfans gekommen. Ich weiß gerade gar nicht, wann die Sendung war. Ich suche sie nochmal raus. Ich werde sie in den Shownotes verlinkt haben, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Es gab mehrere Fälle von Polizeigewalt und aber auch von Faneskalationen, also beidseitig, und dann die eines gestorbenen Fans. Da habe ich damals noch darüber gesprochen, hier im Rasenfunk, weil damals der Innenminister, der aus der Fanszene kommt, ganz anders reagiert hat, als alle Innenminister, die man sonst so kennt. Grüße auch hier an deutsche Innenminister, die Derbys komplett ohne Gästefans fordern. Klar, alles logisch. Was denn alles eigentlich noch? Die armen Fußballfans. Da haben wir auch darüber gesprochen. Da kam das in einigen Nebensätzen auch durchaus mit vor, dass eben diese besondere Situation der Fans, die ja irrere Depressionen in der Serie A zu erdulden haben, eben auch zum Teil zu solchen Verbrüder und manchmal auch Schwesterungen geführt haben in der Serie A. Ich werde es noch mal verlinken. Und dann fehlt uns noch dein Moment, Nils.
Ja, vom 33. Spieltag, der im Moment das Spiel dazu hatte ich vorhin schon leicht angedeutet. Das war der Kampf um Platz 4. Den hat Atletico mit 3-1 für sich entschieden. Bei diesem Spiel kam es primär zu einer unschönen Situationsszene, aber daraus ist der Moment des Spieltags geboren. Nico Williams wurde vermeintlich rassistisch beleidigt. Zumindest hat er in der ersten Halbzeit irgendwann den Schiedsrichter darauf hingewiesen. Da gab es gerade gewisse Geräusche. Egal, darum geht es jetzt hier nicht. Sondern darum, dass er, ich glaube, 5 Minuten später, selbst den Ausgleich erzielt hat und dann beim Torjubel wieder in diese Ecke gelaufen ist und dabei ganz klar mit dem Finger auf seiner Haut gezeigt hat, um da eben den Atletico-Fans zu zeigen, hey, guck mal, darauf kommt es an. Und von dem her war das eine besondere Szene, auch wenn natürlich kein schöner Hintergrund, wie es dazu kam. Aber da hat er ein gutes Zeichen auf den Platz gegeben. Hat am Ende nicht gereicht, Atletico hat 3-1 gewonnen. Aber das war schon bemerkenswert. Wie dann auch generell, das Spiel wurde unterbrochen. Auch die Atletico-Spieler haben da interveniert und eben die Fans gebeten, so geht es nicht weiter.
Ja, das wollte ich eben fragen, was dann eigentlich die Maßnahmen waren, weil das mit dem Vorwurf habe ich mitbekommen, aber das heißt, es wurde quasi unterbrochen und so.
Genau, da hat das La-Liga-Protokoll dann gegriffen, dass der Schiedsrichter wirklich das Spiel für ein paar Minuten unterbrochen hat. Die Mannschaften blieben auf dem Platz. Stadion-Durchsage natürlich, auch die Atletico-Spieler waren da sehr engagiert, um auf ihr Publikum einzuwirken. Mittlerweile gibt es jetzt Diskussionen, waren das wirklich solche Geräusche oder solche Geräusche, also auch dafür, aber ich meine, der Spieler hat was gehört und hat dann selbst darauf hingewiesen, dass da was gab, von dem her gibt es da für mich nicht viel Spielraum. Der La Liga-Verband hat natürlich dann auch an die verantwortlichen Behörden weitergeleitet. Ich meine, auch eine Person wurde dann schon irgendwie festgenommen, rausgeführt, aber da ist dann auch immer viel Unklares im Raum. Aber so gesehen, diese La Liga-Protokolle-Maßnahmen greifen dann schon und hatten ja auch in den letzten Jahren hier und da schon Übung oder konnten ausgiebig getestet werden, leider.
Und ich würde mal so sagen, wenn du Geräusche von dir gibst, die missverstanden werden könnten als rassistische Beleidigung, dann gibst du vielleicht einfach generell die falschen Geräusche von dir in einem Stadion. Da ist es dann vielleicht auch nicht so wichtig, was es jetzt ganz genau war. Aber gut, das war unser Blick auf die Champions League und auf La Liga und Serie A. In der nächsten Ligatur haben wir dann sicherlich auch wieder die Premier League und vielleicht auch die Ligue 1 mit dabei. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ich hoffe, euch hat die Sendung dennoch gefallen. Mir hat es große Freude gemacht, weil es auch mal schön war, ausführlich über die Champions League zu sprechen und sogar hier im Real Life und dann gespoilert werden vom Spiel. Also ganz herzlichen Dank an euch beiden. Herzlichen Dank an Mario Rieker von Serie Amore natürlich. Und herzlichen Dank an Nils Kern vom Tiki-Taka-Podcast und von Viva La Liga. Danke dir, lieber Nils. Okay, da distanzierst du dich jetzt auf einmal. Oh je, was ist dir da vorgefallen? Ja, Real Total, hast du natürlich recht. Es ist ja sowieso alles verlinkt immer in den Shownotes. Und eigentlich werden es die Hörerinnen und Hörer schon gewusst haben. Also herzlichen Dank an euch beide. Und ich danke natürlich auch Menschen, die diese Sendung möglich gemacht haben. Das sind in diesem Fall Bitzel, MostlyMad, Hannah, Anton, Martin, Georg, Klaas und Daniel T. Sie alle haben uns finanziell unterstützt. Und weil alles hier im Rasenfunk von euch finanziert ist, danken wir an dieser Stelle stellvertretend für euch alle jetzt diesen genannten Personen auf rasenfunk.de/supporterscluberfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Tut das gerne, empfehlt uns weiter, bleibt gesund und bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut. Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.